سوف نتغلب دائمًا على الشر،
هذه الأكاذيب هي جوهر تقاليدنا
وتقاليدك أيضًا،
ولكن الأفق لا يظل واضحًا لفترة من
الوقت بمجرد هزيمة الشر القديم،
يحاول الشر الجديد أن يرفع رأسه،
هل لديك شعور  أن الشر سوف
ينهار مرة أخرى
أستطيع أن أرى
في أعينكم الآن أننا نفكر بنفس الطريقة التي
تفكرون بها، فنحن نعلم أن الحرية ستنتصر، ونعلم أننا نعلم أن
روسيا ستخسر،
ونعلم حقًا أن
النصر سيغير العالم، وهذا
سوف  سيكون التغيير الذي يحتاجه العالم منذ فترة طويلة،
المملكة المتحدة
تسير معنا نحو تحقيق أقصى استفادة
وأعتقد أن أهم انتصار في
حياتنا سيكون انتصارًا على
فكرة العالم ذاتها
بعد أن ذهبنا معًا أي معتدٍ
لا يفعل ذلك  سيعرف الأمر الكبير أو الصغير
ما ينتظره إذا هاجم
النظام الدولي
أي معتدٍ
أي معتدٍ سيحاول دفع
البنداريين بالقوة الذين سيلحقون
الدمار والموت بالشعوب الأخرى
الذين سيحاولون تحمل دكتاتوريته
السابقة على حساب
دماء الآخرين في
حروب إجرامية وغير مبررة كما يفعل الكرملين
سيخسر أي معتدٍ